[Música]
ruas e bairros
onde está este trem de cima
ele fala comigo ou ele se vira e fica com você
não recebo duas derrotas todos são amigos
eles não estão preocupados com essa regra e vêm com
minha palma não me protegeu saiu daqui
A magnitude chilena é muito homem
maneiras baratas
ela é minha mais velha
Porque
[Música]
não é mais
há muita estima yucca
[Aplausos]
seu
você não vai ter cicatrizes de ambiente morno
melhor medir o que eu sou muito pouco
nós mito humano uma hora sagrada
preso que era uma metade de sangue
grande prêmio nas mãos de sua falta de um
missão de fazer o mago esquecer isso
todas as sombras de estátuas loucas e francas que
saem quando são registrados e não há
vocação apoiada pela mesma pessoa minha
solidão
e eu chego me facilitou de um pode ver
que é verdade e que vamos continuar
gatinho pouco crédito e minha navalha
algo difícil porque de Cádiz e banda dupla
tem um gosto diferente
Eu gosto assim quando eu vim com
todos nós aprendemos que um
pessoa chega ao set
2018 se você está fazendo
estou sofrendo uma benção
e com meus privilégios eu não gosto com um
mundo vivo declina melhor da europa
de qualquer maneira visite uma barraca
tensão máxima para um novo idioma
quando nada acontece no clube e é isso
que eu estava com você
[Música]
eles estão preocupados, mas sim
na minha província era suicida e
chileno hora de sofrer vivoratá
maneiras
[Música]
mais
linda você é minha machuca
[Aplausos]
viu
e eu te amo mais